Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's and Michelle Hamburger, and today we're going to talk about
chemotherapy and
peripheral neuropathy
So do we get a lot of people complain about them?
Yes, so the majority of the patients that start with Conner's clinic have either already gone through
the traditional system and have done chemotherapy and radiation or
come to us at a late enough stage or their cancer is significant enough that they choose to do chemotherapy and
peripheral neuropathy or chemo-induced peripheral neuropathy is
incredibly common and
can be very debilitating and so we are asked often
what is it that a patient can do naturally?
to help either
prevent some of those effects or eliminate them once they've already come into place
We had a patient just yesterday
Tell me that her oncologist said that if her peripheral neuropathy had not abated by a year in that she would never
ever have relief from it
for the rest of her life and
So just wondering if you can comment on that and what it is that our clinic can do to support patients in this
Well, I put up this picture on this slide here because I
Wanted to relate it back to what we were talking about with some other members, but it's just recently about
Oxidate of stress what chemotherapy is is an oxidizing agent and oxidizing agents damage cells
Well, that's the goal with chemotherapy. We wanted to damage cells. We wanted to be a poison
to
Cancer cells, but the problem is it's not just a poison. The cancer cells
It's a poison to other cells as well and when it damages neurons
then you end up with neurons that are
died and
then paid is not and paid and tinglyed and and
Different types of pain that you get with the rompathy like birding pain and tingly pain
Those things are no longer
Inhibited because the fibers that typically inhibit those those pain
sensations have died off because of the oxidative stress caused from the chemotherapy
So we talk about chemotherapy induced peripheral neuropathy. It's because the chemotherapy has basically
Killed neurons that are supposed to be
Inhibiting these pain these pain sensations
So we talked about that we don't want to just load up a
high dose anti-oxidance when we are
Currently doing the chemotherapy
Because we want the chemotherapy that oxidizing agent to effectively kill cancer cells
But about 48 hours after chemotherapy is done
After our infusion that's when we could use detox therapies to help pull that out so it does less damage on
other
Parts of our body other cells including neurons
So if it's killing neurons, it's killing other cells too. So we've had patients literally
Family members get autopsies of past patients who passed away
Prove that they ended up passing away from
chemotherapy induced cirrhosis of the liver
Well, how would that happen? Well because chemotherapy kills cells. It doesn't
Specifically only target cancer cells it kills your healthy cells as well. So
Are there things that we could do
Post chemotherapy to help preserve and protect healthy cells
And healthy neurons and to also if I already have neuropathy to regenerate those neurons
And your other cells including your liver and all your other cells your body can we regenerate those
To to regate a level of health that we are currently lacking
And that's where we want to talk about some of the therapies so you can speak about a few of these Michelle
Sure um, so one of the benefits with the iam pro wave and part of the reasons why
we
Have patients doing this as part of their chemotherapy protocol
Is the benefit of extracting excess toxins from the body
toxins can
Damage cells and their ability to function the toxins in chemotherapy as dr. Connors was just saying will actually kill those cells and so
Once you are finished with your chemo or if you are doing a chemo protocol running the iam pro wave
Is going to draw out some of those excess toxins that have no longer served or are done
Serving their purpose and you don't need them in your body any longer and you can draw those out so that they are no longer
affecting
Your cells in a toxic or oxidizing manner. So the iam pro wave is excellent
Uh, secondly the pemf
The pemf is a phenomenal cellular
regenerative device that we have seen excellent results in we've had several
Patients that would deal with peripheral neuropathy that have had a great relieving of their symptoms and have seen
Sensation correct sensation come back into their hands and feet by doing the pemf if you
Have access to one of these in a clinic near you or you come to Connors clinic
To do pemf sessions
You would request that the pads be put either underneath your feet or underneath your hands
And so that you're concentrating the bulk of the delivery into
The appendages that are most affected by the neuropathy do you want to and the rebuilder is another
Picture we have on the slide
That is a
Electrical stimulating device that has FDA approval for neuropathy and that's where you put your you can put the pads as sticky pants
Kind of looks like a little tins unit, but it stimulates at the frequency of the nerve
That's why it can be so helpful to rebuild a nerve and
Help that regrow and strengthen and it's been proven to be excellent for neuropathy
Typically, we do it with the pads in a bucket of water
And we can give you instructions on how to do that. That is an FDA approved device
I put up a picture of niacinabide B6 actually we should use the B6 niacinabide
Notice that so I look at this that that's the wrong picture, but
That is another supplement. There's a whole bunch of other supplements that you could use to help
Detox you could use keylators
To help detox that you can support the liver detox pathways and most certainly
With our patients we run a genetic profile because we want to look at a pond pathway that in a tea pathway
These are specific genetic pathways
That if a person has defects on that pathway, they're going to be more susceptible to
Negative effects of chemo therapy
And most certainly we want us more specifically support those pathways
So hopefully this gives you a brief understanding of yes, you can help rebuild those nerve pathways
Yes, you can help detox
The negative effects of chemo therapy out of your body
But the longer you do have the damage the longer it's going to take to rebuild that so you want to jump out this as soon as possible
Thank you very much. Bye-bye